[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul and this video i'm joined
by jared to talk about where we want to
see a sequel to prey go we stan she slay
we hope we pray we get a pray too so we
can follow naru all day but i'm not a
rapper as i'm sure you can guess we love
the movie so i thought we'd break down
exactly where we want to see things
going in the future if you have your own
ideas then make sure you drop them below
and don't forget to subscribe for videos
like this every day without the way huge
thank you for clicking this jared where
you at
thanks chump i mean paul now the closing
credits of prey sets up an interesting
tease for prey too showing naru and her
tribe turn to the sky and see predator
ships approaching now whether or not a
sequel will happen remains unknown but
with the positive reviews and word of
mouth it seems inevitable however when
and where this sequel takes place is an
interesting wrinkle for sure director
dan trechtenberg said in an interview
with sci-fi wire in time out we have
lots of thoughts how could we ever turn
off the thoughts about fun and exciting
things but certainly what was really
exciting about the credit sequence was
what would be in any other movie an end
tag a live action tag in addition to the
credits that our end credits sequence
actually has a story point in it i think
is really awesome there are a lot of
exciting ideas for what could be next
for the franchise the things that most
excite me are the boldest swings and i
think there's scope to do things that
haven't been done before so from
trachtenberg's statements the predators
do in fact return at the end of the film
we just don't see it in you know a
traditional sense of well
mcu post-credit stingers
so with this limited information we can
turn to the thing that connects prey to
the later predator films specifically
predator 2. that's the flintlock pistol
sporting the name raphael adelini dated
1715. obviously this is the piss still
nero is in possession of at the end of
prey but also if you don't know this is
the same pistol that's gifted to
harrigan at the end of predator 2. this
came from the greyback predator meaning
that somehow he got it from nauru now
before this was sort of retconned by
prey the story of the pistol was told
through a 1997 dark horse comic called
predator 1718 this featured the
character rafael adelini and essentially
he was a pirate that had his munitions
crew turn on him he teamed up with a
greyback predator to fight them off and
all seemed well until a strangler crew
member shot adelini in the back in his
final few moments he gifted the pistol
to the predator as a sign of friendship
and faith and that is how the weapon
showed up in predator 2. it was a trophy
in a sense but in many ways it was also
a sign of their allegiance now another
example of this good faith practice is
briefly shown by the predators in 2004's
avp where they make an alliance out of
mutual respect i think it'll be very
difficult to explain how the greyback
predator was given the pistol lost it to
some french fur traders and then it
wound up with nauru all in a year's time
so my guess is that the predator 1718
comic storyline is more than likely
retconned but we could see things hinted
at in a future film however most studios
are normally like them comics though so
it's probably a goner unless they're
struggling for plot ideas in the future
i do think that the pistol will pop up
time and time again though and
potentially they could use it as this
cool little thing that constantly
connects all the movies together you
could have this species come down and
take it from nauru then we could get
another film where someone ends up
taking it from them they get it back and
basically play passy the parcel across
the next couple of centuries could be
like the star wars disney plus stuff
where they keep trying to squeeze as
much as they can out of that time
between revenge and new hope and we
might end up getting it constantly
showing up throughout the timeline now
with the predators returning to earth
there are a handful of different ways
that this could play out some more
exciting than others one of which could
simply be the predators coming back to
pick up their friend discover he was
bested by nero and be like ah man jimmy
didn't make it and fly off to another
planet
[Music]
that's all folks
that's probably not the way that anyone
wants to see a follow-up to prey go down
so instead the predators arrive back to
earth discover their friend has been
bested and searched for answers to whom
or what is behind this following their
methodology of moving up the food chain
will lead them to the komachi and naru
with the predator still building upon an
established code of honor they instead
will enact revenge against neru where
the full might of the kamachi led by
neru will go up against a handful of
predators this could set up a cool cat
and mouse approach similar to 2010's
predators or 2004's avp where each
predator will be baited into a different
terrain or scenarios by the kamachi
using their intellect tracking skills
herbs and more to go up against the
predators more advanced weaponry for
example the ships are going to be a huge
headache for the bows arrows and spears
of the kamachi but the herb that cools
their blood and hides their body heat is
essentially a bare bones version of the
predator's camouflage which will help
them bypass their stronger tactics if in
fact they do use their ships and as
we've learned from prey along with the
original 1987 predator movie the back to
basics primitive approach to warding off
the predators has proven time and time
again to be the best way to go about it
the reason is so obvious because the
predators are too reliant on some of
their technology and have forgotten how
a prey will react in certain situations
boiling it down to its most basic points
animal instincts are what naroon dutch
used to best the predator they blended
in with their environment used bows and
spears that didn't carry a heat
signature and also found their own ways
to make themselves invisible the bare
bones strategy binds them with their
environment using it to their favor now
this in turn could also lead to another
final showdown with nauru and one of the
predators going back and forth they
could hit a point where it's
communicated with the alien that narue
was responsible for the first predator's
fate witnessing her fighting skills that
predator could then develop the mutual
respect culture that we've seen in the
later films on the other hand i could
see them somewhat adapting the raphael
adeline's storyline from the dark horse
comics where the predators come back
discover nauru and see there's this
third-party threat to both her people
and also the predators for example even
more fur traders and frontiersmen could
arrive causing nauru and the predators
to actually team up in the skirmish nero
could be unfortunately killed off and in
her last moments she might give the
pistol to the predator this would be
much like rafaela delaney in the comics
and it would explain how the weapon made
its way to predator 2. now if they take
more of a bold approach like
trachtenberg mentioned in his interview
and do not go with a direct sequel to
prey and instead do a bit of a time jump
i.e predator to predator 2 there is a
300 year span of places the predator
could wind up they could even drop in
before that time era i mean who am i to
make these rules now i'm not saying we
pull a bill and ted's excellent
adventure version of the predator even
though seeing the predators hunt through
time like the opening credits of x-men
origins wolverine would be pretty cool
but imagine a predator is dropped off to
hunt in the middle of feudal japan the
viking age the bill cosby show okay
maybe not that last one but there's
plenty of primitive lore and time erase
that the predator could be exposed to if
i were to guess time era or event i
would potentially say world war one or
world war ii solely based off of a clue
that is again hidden in predator 2. when
harrigan is given the flintlock pistol
if we zoom into the wrist of the elder
predator right before he tosses over the
pistol you can catch an insignia for the
united states 2nd infantry division this
division was formed all the way back in
1917 and was active through world war 1
world war ii and as recent as the iraq
war so the elder predator who visited
nauru in the 1700s grabbing the pistol
as a trophy could have easily visited
european countries and a world war one
battlefield potentially hunting both the
allies and the central powers with one
of the soldiers from the second infantry
division either besting a predator or
having teamed up with him similar to the
rafael adelini or naru situation than
dying in the predator's arms gifting the
predator with their insignia as a trophy
of good faith much like the pistol what
i love about the predator franchise is
that the series has the potential to be
full of visits to the past they're
creatures that could have popped up in
major places throughout history and
there's so much potential here for them
to constantly show up anyway that's
where we'd love to see things go in the
future and obviously we'd also love to
hear your thoughts on where you think
things are gonna go too comment below
and let me know and just to let you know
we're running a competition right now
and giving away three copies of doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness on
the 15th of august all you have to do to
be on the chance of winning is like the
video make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts and theories we
picked the comments at random on the
15th and the winners of the last one on
screen right now save that to you
message me on twitter at heavyspoilers
you want some else to watch then make
sure you check out our breakdown of prey
which will be linked on screen right now
we talk about the pistols origins in way
more detail and also go over the film's
plot if not thanks for sending through
the video hope you enjoyed it i've been
paul he's been jared and i'll see you on
the next one take care peace